[Music]  so you old boring shift too much dad  it's like a puncture one boys cross town  just caught two more bodies said both  had some kind of a mark on their neck  three reign and victims at the times of  death of minutes apart bodies a miles  apart has that worked  [Music]  hello Thomas what'd you say this is  where it happens  today marks the nine-year anniversary of  the Market Street murders and a still  unidentified suspect detective Lockhart  yes hello we mean seven in a game you  guys gotta see this Philly PD it seems  woman nice to see you again she gets 25  by a train and nine years later she's  back she is priority number one for all  law enforcement agencies you have to  stop chasing me I'm doing all this for a  reason  [Music]  you have no idea what's coming  if you kill me now the world as you know  it will end  you